so far in circular motion
uh we've looked at the fact that if
we've got and we really spent the bulk
of our time on uniform circular motion
because that's what most of it is and
when it's not uniform you can't do as
many interesting things with it
in any kind of circular motion
you've got to have some kind of
centripetal force essentially before you
remember what that means it's facing
toward the center right we looked at
this and we said well that that force
that's acting toward the center right it
can come from a variety of things it
might come from
tension in a string some kind of medium
like that right it might come from if
this is like you know a celestial body
or planet something like that that force
might come from gravity okay
and we noticed that it had to be just
the right amount of force
it had to be
m r omega squared or or m v squared on r
right what would happen if it was just a
little bit too much force pulling toward
the center what would happen
it would spiral in that's exactly right
um this force is just enough to change
the direction of velocity so it goes
around at this curve but if it's too
great it'll change it too much right and
it'll start to go inward and annoying
and if it's not enough conversely what
would happen
it would spiral outwards right it would
go wee and it wouldn't it wouldn't get
caught okay
so
these are the two ideas that we've been
looking at right
but i have this question to you right uh
we were talking about strings with
tension or um planets with gravity
we actually observe though many things
that move in circles like this okay but
there's no string holding the thing in
and there's no gravity necessarily
holding it
uh and the the easiest example i can
think of
is one of these
oh that's terrible sorry
right so here you go here's a car
you're like oh that's what it is
if i have a car and it's um well let's
just say for the sake of simplicity um
it is doing laps around a circular track
okay now quite obviously
if it's a normal sized car there's no
string with tension holding it toward
the center of the tracks right at the
same time we assume there's no enormous
body exerting gravity on the car that
keeps it on the track so how does it go
in a circle what is the force that keeps
it
face towards the inside any takers
the answer is it's friction
now hold on a second we're kind of used
to we're kind of used to the idea of
like even when we move around right
friction is kind of what slows you down
you you you roll something and then
eventually it will stop because friction
will stop it right well the idea is that
friction
is mainly a reaction force right
when something's pushing against
something and friction will push back
okay now what's happening is this car is
going around okay well according to
inertia right the first law which way
does that car with all of its inertial
mass which way does it want to go
is it that there's there's two options
for inertia right it's either going to
be at rest is it at rest
no or it'll be
uniform
straight line motion right so what it
wants to do is not bend around like this
it wants to
keep going right so the normal sort of
situation is the default situation for
this car is um is this kind of situation
right so it's going outward
so therefore the friction force it's
reacting against that right and so
there's a sideways force acting toward
the middle and that's what's keeping it
in the circular path right now that is
why it's so important that there is um
there is grip
on the tires
and on the road right because if you
take that grip away
then what happens there's not enough
friction right this will take over and
it'll skid outwards okay
so that's why you know rainy conditions
or if the tires on your car are really
old and bald and don't have enough grip
on them then you're going to have this
you're going to go off in the direction
of the tangent actually that's where
you're going to go
so this is kind of a problem but we sort
of overcome it with tires but there's
another way to overcome it there's
another way to overcome it so road
designers take advantage of these things
called and here's our um
here's our final thing
what are called banked tracks
a bank track is where you are turning
around right what they do is they put an
embankment they raise part of the road
not all of it okay so that there's a
force acting inward okay i want you to
remember
the ball the enormous two meter across
hemispherical ball we were looking at
right
okay we're looking at this yesterday
right we noticed that well okay you've
got
this circular path being traced out you
do have well we had a string up here
attached which was exerting tension
right but then there was another force
involved that was also pushing in which
force was that
was the normal force right so if this is
where i am you know the normal force is
going there perpendicular to the surface
of the bulb or perpendicular to the
surface of whatever you're on um ball
cone all those kinds of things okay
so the bank tracks take advantage of
this let's draw one and you'll see
what's going on
first we'll do it side on so you do a
little sort of triangle like this
okay now this is a bit of exaggeration
um you almost never see a bank track
that is this steep but if we make it
realistic it's hard to see what's going
on okay
so instead of the road being flat okay
part of the road
the outside of the turn
is embanked up okay and then this thing
it curves around
okay so there's the turn so we're
looking on from there just to make it a
little bit clearer i might put in
there's an edge here that we can't see
this outside bottom edge of the
embankment so if i dot that
i went a bit higher there you can kind
of see what's going on okay so
what's happened is as we go around this
turn
okay
there's going to be a normal force right
the normal force is going in that
direction so you can see when we resolve
it right it'll have a vertical part
right but it also has a horizontal part
that is centripetal it's headed toward
the center of the turn so this is going
to help our car stay on the road and not
do this thing okay
so to understand this situation and know
what's going on let's put a bit more on
detail onto this so catch up draw this
diagram and let's start to label some
bits onto it
we've got our normal force there
what's another force that's acting on
this thing
gravity good so let's put that on
okay there you go
now it's um it is circular you don't
need to have all of i mean you know we
talked about a car doing laps around a
circular track but that's not usually
what's happening usually we want to
actually do a turn and not just go round
and round and round but there is still
for this arc right there is still a
center to this okay now watch out
there's a couple there's lots of
different centers that i can talk about
here because there are lots of different
circles that i could draw for instance
here is a um a center of the circle and
it's on the flat of the ground okay not
on the high-end banked part right
but it's not very useful to us this this
particular center is not very useful to
us because if you're driving along in
your car right
so here's my car
and um you're driving along this road
okay
the center of the mass of the car right
should be on the center of the road and
that's why i've drawn my object and all
of the forces acting on it i've drawn it
at the center there okay
now that's raised off the ground can you
see that so therefore i'm going to raise
the center that i'm interested in also
off the ground so something like here
i'm guessing
so there is the actual center of motion
if i picture a horizontal circle now it
lines up like this this would be the
radius
there's the radius of the actual
circular motion okay
i'll
mark that as the center okay
we need to know what angle this is
embedded at so i'll call this angle over
here theta this is at a right angle
you've got a height
here of the raised edge
and then lastly we need to know the
width of the road
so we'll call that
d for distance okay